Sarah Paulson wins her first Emmy award
now the responsibility of playing a real
person is an enormous one you want to
get it right not for you but for them
the 41 year old actress won the emmy for
outstanding actress in a limited series
or movie for her role as the famous
lawyer Marcia Clark in the People vs OJ
Simpson American crime story Sarah not
only won the Emmy she got to share the
win with Marcia Clark herself and got
emotional over being wrong about her in
the past the more I learned about the
real Marcia Clark the more I had to
recognize that I along with the rest of
the world had been superficial and
careless in my judgment and I'm glad to
be able to stand here today in front of
everyone and tell you I'm sorry
backstage et spoke with Sarah about her
relationship with Marcia I know you've
gotten to know her a lot better through
this whole process I good friend yeah
you said she's different than you
imagined she you pictured the
two-dimensional person and now she's
different sure the two-dimensional
person because it's what we it's what we
believed and that we all saw from the
trial and what was sort of fed to us via
the media at the time and once I did any
further looking it became very clear
what a very very deep complicated
wonderful smart woman she was in what
battle she was fighting so yeah it
became a very different picture